Welcome everybody to this
episode of functional programming 101.
In this lecture we're going to do
something slightly different.
We're not going to introduce new
concepts.
What we're going to do is, we're going to
show you
how a typical development,
transformational development
of programs in Haskell works.
The general pattern is that
you start with an obviously correct
solution
that usually uses a lot of brute force
and is super inefficient. And then
you use refactoring to make it more
efficient.
But the first goal is to write the
simplest program
that works no matter how inefficient it
is.
And then you start refactoring it.
There's many similarities with
extreme programming and things like
that.
Just do the minimal things to make it
work and then later
we will try to optimize it and
maybe it's not necessary to optimize.
Because even if something is quadratic,
maybe you never use it on big
inputs.
Or all the inputs that you get can
run in reasonable time
and you can spend your time better
on other things.
No premature optimization. Make sure
that things are correct first and then
optimize
later. One thing that we won't show here
is that you can also take your
Haskell code,
use it as a prototype, once you're happy
with it
you implement the same
algorithm in another language that is
maybe more efficient.
But, depending
on the particular program it might, the
Haskell Compiler might already do a
good job
but sometimes it's not just about speed
that you want to use a different
language
but it is because
in your company they're not using
Haskell but say PHP.
Remember one of the mottos of this
course
is "Think like a fundamentalist
but code like a Hacker".
This is what we will see here. We
start with a very fundamentalist thing, it
has to be correct
and then we'll hack on the
code
to make it more efficient.
The problem we're going to look at is the
so-called
countdown problem. Countdown problem
is based on a quiz program on British
TV that has been there for a while.
It's originally based on a French TV show.
In that show
there's a game that we call here
the countdown problem. If you
Google for "sudoku solver in Haskell" or
if you read any of Richard Bird's
papers, you will
see a very similar development. This is
very idiomatic Haskell development.
Let's look at what this countdown problem
is first in an informal way.
What we need to do is, given
a set of numbers and the standard
operators, addition,
subtraction, multiplication and
division
we need to create an expression whose
value is some given value. In this case
we say
we have to create an expression whose
value is
765. Now for humans
this can be hard because the search
space
is rather big. We have to try
all possible combinations with
parenthesis
and whatever to find the answer. This
is fun in a quiz show
and some people are really good at it,
can do it fast, other people
fail, but this is something
computers are good at.
Because computers have infinite
patience.
They can churn through this
search space
and find a solution. If we can
restrict the search page enough
it might even be able to find the
solutions
very quickly. That will be the case
for this example. There's a couple of more
rules.
It's that all numbers including
intermediate results must be natural
numbers, they must be positive,
each of the numbers in the original set
can be used only once
and then there's another set of rules but
we keep things simple, right here.
In particular let's look at a possible
solution.
In our case, using the numbers
25, 10, 50 and 1 we can create
765 as follows: and notice that
25-10 is a positive number
50+1 is a positive number and
when you multiply two positive numbers
they are
positive as well. Alright,
for this particular example the
search space
consist of 780 possible solutions
but if we slightly change
the result value then
suddenly we can find no solution.
We go from 780 possible solutions
to no solutions.
Let's start to build a solution to
this program
bottom-up, were going to start
by building the pieces and then we glue
everything together to solve the problem.
Erik
come on, You make a mess.
Ok here we go, what we're going to do
is we'll define our
operators as an algebraic data type,
so we have addition
subtraction, multiplication and division.
What we're going to do is we're
going to define
an evaluation function that takes two
numbers and applies
the operator. It's
straightforward whenever you want to add
two numbers,
you add two numbers. Whenever
you want to subtract them you
subtract them
et cetera. The reason we're using
this representation and not immediately
evaluating them
is because we want to build
a symbolic representation of the
expression.
Because we don't want to find the
number
765, we want to find an expression that
when you evaluate it
will return this number.
We want to do symbolic processing of
expressions and then once we have
an expression we can
evaluate it with this function. Now let's
encode
the rules of the game. One of the
rules was
that every operator
must be applied to positive numbers
so let's check whether when we
apply an operator that it's a valid
application of that operater. If we add
two numbers
we don't have to check.
Because if we add two positive numbers the result
will be positive.
If we must, make sure
that the first number is bigger than the
second number
because otherwise the result would be
negative and that's not allowed.
Multiplying two positive numbers
is always positive and when we divide
two numbers
we have to check that they are actually
divisible, because otherwise we don't
get
a natural number.
Now we can define the data type
of expressions, just as we have seen
before. We have a slightly different...
instead of having
a separate constructor for each
operator we have...
We have only application that takes these
operators.
How can we evaluate an
expression?
Well we evaluate an expression,
either we return a singleton list
that contains the value or
when the expression is not valid
anywhere inside, we return the empty
list.
You will recognize this trick
from our parsers. Our parser also
returned either an empty lest when they
failed,
or a singleton list with the result
when they succeeded.
We don't use the Maybe type,
we're using lists because it's much more
convenient.
If you are a Haskell programmer
and you're using the Maybe type, please
reconsider to use lists.
Because, as you see here,
its a little bit nicer because you can use
list comprehension like this.
Let's see how the evaluation works.
Again
it's defined recursively over expressions,
we either have a value, well in that case
it succeeds
if the expression
the value is greater than 0 and if we
have an expression that is the
application of an operator to two sub-
expressions
what do we do? We evaluate the left hand
side,
we evaluate the right hand side.
We check
that the application of this operator,
to these numbers, is valid.
If that's the case we return
that application there.
Really what you see here is that it's an
evaluation intermixed with a filter
for only valid sub-expressions.
Now let's continue to
formalize the problem. There's a
few more helper functions that we
need and these helper functions I will
just assume that they exist
but you will get them in your exercises.
So, hahaha,
I can assume that they exist but you
will have to define them.
That's the advantage of teaching a course.
The first function here that we're
going to use is choices.
Choices takes a list of values of
type a
and returns a list of lists that
gives you all possible ways of choosing zero
or more
elements from this input list.
It's not as
complicated as it sounds.
Let's look at a concrete example.
If I want to have all the choices of the
list [1,2].
These are all the possible ways of
choosing zero or more elements from that
list.
I can choose 0 elements, I can choose one
element, so that can be [1] or [2]
and then I can choose [1,2]
or I can choose [2,1]
those are two possible ways to choose two
values
from that list. You see
that thing here and again I will assume
that this function exists you will have
to define that
in the exercises. Now we can define a new
function
that given an expression returns
a list of all the values.
All the values, what are those?
Those are all the values at the leaves.
If I have a value I return a
singleton list.
If I have the application of whatever
operator
I take the values of the left
sub-expression and combine them with the
values
of the
right sub-expression. Now we can
decide if some expression is a solution
for a given list of numbers by
more or less directly translating the
rules of the game
into this Haskell program. Given an
expression
this is our list of initial numbers and
this our target number now we have to
check
whether this expression here is a
solution
to the problem. What this says is
that
first of all the expression must
evaluate
to the number that we're looking for.
That was a number that we're
required to find so
when we evaluate the expression it must
use that number and then
when we take all the values in that
expression
and we take all the possible choices
for the input numbers
that thing, that list
must be a member of that list.
If you go back
to the English description of the
countdown problem
you will see that this is a very nice
direct translation of that definition.
Now let's
look at a brute-force solution that
searches
for all possible solutions.
To do that we will use another
function
that you will have to define in the
exercises
and this is the function split.
Split takes a list and returns a pair of lists
inside another list
and it will give if you all the possible ways
that you can split that list into a pair
of lists.
If we want to split [1,2,3,4]
I split it into [1]
[2,3,4]. I can split in [1,2] and [3,4].
I can
split it in [1,2,3] and [4] and
note that we don't take into account
the empty list.
Splitting [1,2,3,4] into []
and [1,2,3,4] doesn't really make sense
because then I have not
really split the list. I've just split off
the empty list
which is nonsense. Again
this is a function that you will have to
write in the exercises.
Alright
now we can define a function
that given a list of integers will
return
a list of expressions whose values that are
in that expression are
exactly that list of given numbers.
If we're given an empty list of
numbers
then we can build no expression.
If we are given
a singleton list, well the only
expression we can build
that contains that value is the
expression
that contains that value. Now
if we are given a list of numbers
how can be build all the expressions?
Well we split the list
and then recursively use the left side
to create an expression the right side
to create an expression
and then we're using our combine
function
to combine the two. This is a
brute-force
way of enumerating
all possible expressions that are built
out of these numbers. And the
combine function here
just tries to combine these two
expressions
using any of the operators.
What we can do
is we can write a list comprehension that
says
give me all the choices for this
input list, brute force create all
the expressions
and make sure that the value that I'm
looking for
is the required value.
This
solution here, is a more or less
one-to-one translation of the original problem
it's super brute force but it works.
It works, if we run this on
a very very
slow laptop and we look
look for the solutions for our original
problem it finds the first solution
in under half a second and in under a
minute
it finds all solutions. Even for
this
very simple brute-force solution
this is fast
and it takes about a minute to find
all the solutions. The question is
can we do better? We definitely can
since we are brute forcing all possible
expressions there will be many
expressions that are invalid
and that we're going to have to filter out
later. So if we can
make sure that we're not generating any
invalid expressions
that it's definitely a win.
Let's do a back-of-the-envelope
calculation here
there's possible expressions that we
can build are
33 million and only 5 million of them
are actually valid. And then
what we will do is we will combine
the generation function with the
evaluation function so we will fuse these
two
to make sure that things are rejected
earlier but before we do that this
sequence was rather long
so let's take a well-deserved break
and then see you
in a bit. Thank you.